[Musik]
tina und daniel glück im unglück
bald schon geht es los mit meiner neuen
arbeit ich bin schon etwas aufgeregt
hoffentlich erwische ich den zug noch
wenn ich schnell laufe reicht es noch
es reicht noch auf den zug
danke dass ich bei ihm übernachten
durfte dieser ich bin noch ganz
durcheinander wegen gestern das ist doch
klar tina du weißt doch dass ich immer
für dich da bin wenn du mich brauchst du
bist die beste
ich weiß einfach nicht was ich jetzt
machen soll
ich brauche auch geld damit ich mein
leben finanzieren kann
das verstehe ich gut du brauchst teilt
eine neue stelle als was möchtest du
denn arbeiten
mir gefällt die arbeit in einem
restaurant meine eltern in polen haben
ein hotel
da habe ich früher lange gearbeitet aber
ich möchte nicht mehr in einem burger
laden arbeiten lieber in einem richtigen
und schönen restaurant das macht mich
traurig ich weiß wirklich nicht wie es
jetzt weiter geht also jetzt siehst du
dich um und wir gehen erst mal etwas
frühstücken bist du einverstanden
okay das können wir machen aber ich habe
keine kleider hier komm ich finde sicher
noch eine passende hose für dich
[Musik]
guten tag herr smith herzlich willkommen
bei der investition in zürich vielen
dank
es freut mich sie kennenzulernen wann
sind sie denn in der schweiz angekommen
ich bin gestern gelandet und habe jetzt
in meiner neuen wohnung übernachtet und
wie finden sie ihre neue wohnung
sie gefällt mir gut das große wohnzimmer
ist fantastisch und die aussicht ist
toll
das freut mich jetzt zeige ich ihnen
doch zuerst unsere bank und ihren
arbeitsplatz wir nehmen den fahrstuhl
gleich um die ecke
ihr büro ist im dritten stock gerne
zeige ich es ihnen
vielen dank wie viele personen
arbeitenden in diesem gebäude
es arbeiten 73 personen hier in diesem
haus ich meine 74 jetzt sind sie ja auch
hier
interessant und wie lange arbeiten sie
schon hier
ich bin jetzt im vierten jahr hier
wir sind ein sympathisches team
ich werde ihnen gleich alle in unserer
abteilung vorstellen
darauf freue ich mich
ach der fahrstuhl hält an
[Musik]
hierhin zu kommen war eine gute idee
hier im café bin ich gerne ich mag
dieses café auch und der kuchen schmeckt
immer super
hallo zusammen wir waren doch mal
zusammen in einem deutschkurs nicht
hallo herr hahn ja stimmt wir waren
zusammen im a2 kurs ich weiß leider eure
namen nicht mehr
das tut mir leid das ist nicht schlimm
ich heiße tina und das ist meine
freundin lisa hallo tina und lisa seid
ihr immer noch in der halle deutsch
schule ja wir starten nächste woche mit
dem b2 kurs seit wann arbeitest du hier
im café blue seit einem monat es gefällt
mir gut aber wir haben oft stress weil
uns eine kellnerin fehlt tina hast du
das gehört sie suchen eine kellnerin
ich suche eine neue stelle als kellnerin
darf ich mich bewerben klar macht dass
es wäre toll mit dir zu arbeiten
super dann bringe ich morgen meinen
unterlagen vorbei
gut wie sprecher heute mit meinem chef
und empfehle dich vielen herzlichen dank
für hast du tina manchmal braucht es
glück im unglück
[Musik]
hier ist ihr arbeitsplatz hessen
perfekt vielen dank sie haben hier einen
eigenen computer und alle nötigen
unterlagen damit sie sich zurechtfinden
gut ich kann mir vorstellen dass vieles
anders ist als in new york
ja das stimmt
der computer ist zum beispiel auf
deutsch eingestellt
daran muss ich mich wohl erst noch
gewöhnen
das kriegen sie bestimmt hieß es
hier sehen sie schon einmal herrn
kleinert er gehört auch zu unserer
abteilung
hallo herr kleinert hallo zusammen sind
sie herr mesz ich freue mich sie
kennenzulernen
ja genau
die freude ist ganz meinerseits
verkleinert schön dann haben sie sich
schon einmal kennengelernt
dann würde ich sagen dass ich ihnen den
rest des gebäudes zeige
so jetzt über arbeite ich erst mal mein
lebenslauf und schreibe meine bewerbung
hoffentlich klappt das im café lose sind
auch meine freunde oft
[Musik]
tina nowak guten tag frau nowak
hier spricht herbert vom café blue guten
tag herr bellert ich schreibe gerade die
bewerbung für ihre stelle
ich hoffe sie ist noch frei deswegen
rufe ich sie an der hahn hat mir gesagt
dass sie eine stelle als kellnerin
suchen
ja das ist richtig herbert und ich kenne
das café du da treffe ich mich oft mit
meinen freunden
das trifft sich doch gut wir haben im
moment wirklich viel zu tun und wären
froh wenn sie bereits am wochenende
beginnen könnten frau nowak
wow das ist ja schön zu hören aber sie
haben ja meine bewerbung noch gar nicht
erhalten
ich vertraue heran
und wir sind wirklich in einer notlage
kann ich mit ihnen rechnen frau nowak
aber sicher herbert das freut mich sehr
wann soll ich denn vor ort sein kommen
sie doch bitte am freitag um 15 uhr ins
café geht das ja das geht prima vielen
dank herr bernard dann sehen wir uns am
freitagnachmittag perfekt danke nochmals
dass sie so kurzfristig einspringen mit
können
ich freue mich sie persönlich kennen zu
lernen den lohn besprechen wir dann auch
gleich bis freitag auf wiederhören frank
nowak auf wiederhören herbert
[Musik]
[Applaus]